wait i gotta i gotta add everybody on
discord
where's this live is it on the website
how do i get to my lives
guys i don't wanna use computers
we know where it is oh yes oh perfect
all right at everyone live
on youtube
we got people are happening we got
people how much people we got
14 so far oh look i'm chatting and you
can see me chatting
is so meta by the way check out this
guys i just want to show for it because
i think they did a great job uh this is
a hack rf
it's a software defined radio um
they're great and you should buy one we
didn't make it
i'm not sure in fact this isn't a common
product i'm showing for if you can buy
one amazon they're made by new elac
cool um you can tune to all different
frequencies and stuff it's pretty cool
uh this is a tease oh no it's a comma
two
uh yeah check out the comb too you can
have a comma too
um this is the bootloop experiment this
is the com2 that i fixed boot loops on
uh so yeah
what else we got
this is a black we got black panda over
here
um buy black pandas all right we got
when we get 100 people
we'll tell you more about today's
special day yes that's true
nobel day
we've got 100 oh we got 84. did you just
lost 10 people
you guys come back we can't announce
that 100.
nuke bro says it's at 100. hack rf is
bank
you know what i gotta oh i have a hole
in my tooth and i'm going to the dentist
in an hour
what's nabil day all right we're real
close to our 100 person announcement
threshold four more people check out
this red bull
get in here so we can make our
announcement at 100. all right we're at
103.
it's ready george we're ready by the way
this stream is brought to you by the
summer mask
it's a mask but it's perfect for the
summer it's breathable
all right all right don't make them wait
any longer all right all right all right
um
first i'm gonna read you who is nivea um
nabil is on discord um
and nabil clearly is a comma prime
subscriber that's why
um he has the uh orange
uh and i'm going to read this this this
quote to you
how comma 2 works with your vw golf
is it really that great to have it
nabeel
it's amazing so worth it
knowing what it's like now i would have
easily paid double
jason replies put that in a tweet you
could probably get comma to promote
retweet it
nabil haha i mean it's a bit of a
double-edged
sword because i never would have tried
it
if it was double the price however have
tried it
i would now gladly have paid double so
in honor of nabeel
this one you gotta look at me in honor
of nabil and in honor of the crazy
inflation that's going on in this
country right now
we're doubling the price of the count
too
the new price of the comma 2 is 21.98
get your comma twos for only 21.98 in
honor of nabil
uh don't worry don't worry nabil's a
good guy
the bill's a good guy this new price
only applies today
on nobel day maybe
if the nobel day uh on sale is is going
well
maybe we'll keep the higher price um and
because chris isn't here yet this price
isn't live yet on the website so
you know if you buy it right now you can
still get it at the low low price of
of 10.99 but uh you know seriously the
new price of the com2 is 21.98 in honor
of nabeel
um you know i think that it's i think
that it's uh
knowing what it's like now i would have
easily paid double
well you guys can trust nabeel know what
it's like
and pay double what do you all think we
all think is this exciting do you like
this exciting announcement
yeah yeah yeah slow clap yeah all right
cool
um when do you get chevy volt support
we'll see how many people buy on the
bill day
uh we do it we do have something else i
didn't i didn't bring you all in here
but
just in case you missed the nobel day
announcement i see we got a bunch more
people in here now we got 295.
in case you missed the nobel day
announcement we are doubling the price
of the kamato
to 21.99 um
you know look have you tried to buy a
car lately
here let's look up buy a used car price
not videos i think it's a news oh
how much have used car prices going up
in each state
wow crazy amounts
now up by 30 wow that's
crazy so you know i think that between
nabeel's quote and between
what we know about the economy doubling
the price is an insanely reasonable move
uh and one day only nobel day sale all
day sale
just 21.98
yo get in 21.98 let's hope some
corporate people buy out of 21.98
they're looking on 21.99 wow that's
cheaper than like
changing five light bulbs
um
[Music]
all right guys but i really didn't bring
all 300 of you in here just to tell you
that
do we tell them why the other reason we
brought him in
right i think it's time is it time july
31st
july 31st all right guys we uh
leaked it a little bit a couple days ago
uh did you guys see when i posted the
budget the
25 000 we spent on marketing and that
was just the first half of the payment
you guys heard about tesla's autonomy
day we're throwing a
comma autonomy guy um so you guys know
it's my dream to be a famous
rapper uh we rented out this this this
place if you tell me where it is
yeah should we tell them like uh maybe
we don't tell you
the venue's amazing the venues look it's
like a place famous rappers would go man
um this is gonna be sick a lot of famous
people have played there
we got all of comma coming together to
present
uh what we're working on our strategy
for autonomy it's gonna be just like
tesla autonomy day
uh and you guys can buy tickets uh but
not yet because none of that stuff's
live yet this is the pre-teaser
announcement but
if you email alex yeah alex.com ai
uh get in early on comma autonomy day
uh the tickets are reasonably priced and
you know what it will be livestreaming
every person who buys a comment what do
you think of that every person who buys
a comment too on the beat oh
if you buy a coma two today today at the
nobel day price
yes you get a free ticket
before you even know anything about the
tickets you get a free ticket
um to comic-con
uh our our july 31st uh extravaganza
uh autonomy day style event right here
in san diego
uh so you know nobel day is is is is a
great day for everybody
um yeah and there's a very limited
amount of tickets
it's an intimate event it will be live
streamed it will be live stream that's
true
not all of it uh uh the day time will be
live streamed but it's an all-day event
is it all day event uh yeah yeah only
the daytime
live stream we hired professional live
streamers so we're not gonna let's talk
about that for a long
time um yo
yo we spend a lot of money on having
professional live streamers it'll be
streamed on youtube
july 31st wait d grant 22
said if somebody said i didn't really
like the comma but if it was half the
price i would love it
you don't understand you can't troll
nobel day
go up department when the prices go up
department heard about neville
they were like this is a great
opportunity
there will be uh pizza yes wait at the
event
yeah at comic con they'll be pizza oh we
got like i paid a lot of money for food
it better be not just pizza
there's gonna be there should be burgers
burgers there's lunch and dinner
we have lunch and dinner who is nabil
nabil's a hero
nabil is a hero he he's semi-loosened
i don't know what that means but
we know that um so yeah guys comic-con
uh july 31st in san diego
book your plane tickets early before
hyperinflation comes for them too
um how much are tickets
well that's not announced yet but what
is announced is if you buy a comma two
on nobel
day at nobel day prices you get a free
ticket
that's right and i will tell you the
event is gonna sell out
there's a very limited amount of tickets
um
there's gonna be no masks at the event
am i allowed to say that who knows
what's allowed anymore
we have 322 people do you want to answer
maybe some questions
yeah do we have any questions
i raise price geo hot yeah
uh we love high prices guys you want to
see something we didn't read the price
on eons because they're out of stock and
terrible
see what this xeon says on it no for
sale
someone said nabil means profit in
hebrew
that's even better it's like a pun
profit make money and profit
in the future um comma do you believe
you're amazing
uh will there be vegan food yes it'll be
food and allergy friendly food
are the prices only raised for nobel day
yes just today
well the prices will go up again but
this extravagant price increase is only
for nobel day
how can i buy in bulk if you add 10
comma twos to your cart you'll get an
automatic discount i wanna try that
right now let's yeah let's make sure
that still works
check it out so if i go here to buy and
i wanna buy a comma two i click buy now
of course i agree with the thing
if you add more all right watch this
so we're at nine and that's the price
i'm gonna add ten
boom discount buy nine
get one for less than three boom
discount
there you go that's how you buy in bulk
that's what you buy in bulk right there
we built it right into the website so
that we never have to do any business
development
ah your combo was
literally five minutes ago i feel like a
sucker for having paid half the price i
know
some people are going to buy them to
deal day and they're going to know
wait those are they're true fans they're
too fast that's right they're people who
know that no matter
how much they pay for the common two
they're going to feel good about it
because of the value it delivers that's
what nobel day is
all about return it and buy a new one
now you know what you don't even have to
return it you can just buy a new one now
official reveal day um
yeah we'll come with a frisbee will they
come with a frisbee
oh we're thinking about frisbee i'll get
the frisbees today
frisbee we're gonna get comma frisbees
um
what if people buy one in the bld and
get a free ticket with no
intention of attending comic-con oh if
you return your device within 30 you'll
get your ticket after 30 days
you can't you can't buy your device and
return it and keep your ticket no of
course i don't know he's saying that
if you you buy it on the bill day and
you don't want your free ticket
oh what can you do with it it's
non-transferable
it's nonsense horrible well that's
that's what it's not on the bill day
there's no calpers for comic-con there's
not going to be like
people selling comic con tickets on on
ebay
i mean i guess i'm okay with that i'm
okay with that too i think your ticket
is going to be an erc20 we did
talk about doing uh wait should we make
the tickets
nfts on cheapy i think now you're
talking
we're gonna put them on a curve pricing
by the way yeah don't worry about we
thought about doing a bonding curve for
the pricing
um don't worry about by the way uh
your gas fees on jp they're very cheap
how can you return your uh device and
get nobel day pricing yeah you can
if you want to guarantee your ticket oh
where can we send the
1099 to upgrade their current comet 2 to
the nabil day model
oh just buy another car
right now buy it right now at 10.99
right now
in the description just wanted the nobel
day pricing and we'll give you the free
ticket to the conference
they like the no masks i push for it
boys
our policy at the event is is to just
come as you're comfortable oh yeah
i'm not like i'm like you can wear a
mask if you want you can do whatever you
want you can wear whatever you want
if you don't want to wear anything
that's fine no no you got to wear
a shirt and shoes
actually i don't really care about the
shoes
you got to wear a shirt i think bottoms
are the most important are the most
shirt talkers no
[Laughter]
good morning nikki heard about nobel day
yo we're um so nabeel said that
uh if the comma 2 is amazing and so
worth it knowing what it's like now i
would have easily paid double
so today on novel day we're making this
possible and we're raising the price of
21.98
yo it's fun ready it includes a free
comic-con ticket so
[Music]
comma autonomy day um i will say this
um yeah the the screenshot i posted the
discord of our marketing budget was real
uh so the 25 000 was just the deposit
for this event uh so yeah the event's
pretty it's like have you ever been to a
wedding it's like that
but for autonomy
[Laughter]
push-up competition there is going to be
a competition
there's going to be a competition it
won't be push-up stop but let's go
let's go push-ups in honor of the field
day let's go boys
four five two eight
53 17
12. uh
we're getting tuck them elbows george
whoa
whoa that was sick boys that's sick for
him got to do push-ups
and of the deal back
free comma merch at comic-con there's
going to be special
comic-con merch exclusive [ __ ] uh it's
in the back
after the band you can go to the table
man the band was up all night spray
painting the tie-dye
uh
[Laughter]
show them me priceless
any special guest at comic-con
i don't know is there anyone you guys
like to see i think um
eric's going to be the most special
guest can we book jar rule
how much is job
comic-con is is not fire festival
blink 182 pulled out they didn't think
they could provide
the kind of experience their fans were
expecting oh it's not twitch
twitchcon either um
i wish i could love something as much as
george loves hoodies nabil is famous he
has a day named after him
uh soldier boy how are we counting
soldier boy he's into
blockchain now uh
all right boys what else we got
soldier invented autonomy carpathi oh
we'll send him an invite
we'll take care of happening
there's no common beanies it's the
middle of the summer
nabeel should get us giving a deal a
free ticket only if he buys a comment
on the builder that's right i mean does
he want to be a legend
until that's his choice um
can we book elon musk i don't think so
we might be able to put grimes though
leaks on um uh actually adeeb has some
announcements he's going to make
him some announcements he's excited
the or oh a couple people are just one
more time on nobel day
oh yes do you want to post this on our
twitter yeah i think that's a good thing
to post on twitter
uh hang on i got an internal slack so
just
we are thinking about uh letting some of
the community speak at comic-con it's
now live when you add to cart
wow
oh thanks chris did the price already go
live
wow wow the price is live no well i
don't know
refresh i think oh it takes like five
minutes to deploy
yeah yeah because it's got to go through
our oh no
wait it's live here but the subtotal
i don't trust this website oh
sweet yup right here this is the nobel
day pricing it's only partially updated
uh there's a new comma coming what do
you mean a new we have comma twos bros
uh but we are gonna show off so okay
here here's a few things that we're
gonna talk about at comic-con
um so you know we shipped blameless
models
uh laneless models are one of the
biggest breakthroughs for comma and
perhaps you know
uh i mean
i'll tell you guys this went to la
and i went for a ride i didn't drive i'm
happy i didn't drive tesla fc
uh tesla fsd is
not chill uh i went on the same roads
with laneless model
and laneless model was chill um
blameless model is a big uh
a big uh
well breakthrough for for us and then
one of the things we're going to talk
about at
comic con is how we did it and then how
we're also going to apply that same
style to longitudinal and like our
lateral was already quite good
it got better our longitudinals total
crap at least according to consumer
reports weightless longitudinals on park
on lateral so that's one of the things
we're going to talk about
um has a bunch of announcements
developer oriented announcements
we're thinking about doing community
submitted lightning talks we're still
working out the schedule
every uh comma employee is probably
going to speak and then at night
comma jeopardy you guys know a hacker
jeopardy from defcon
comma
um no but uh
i think that everyone who comes to the
event
is going to uh you witnessed a part of
history
is it going to be dev focused or
community a little bit of both
yeah that'll be something that'll be
something for everybody i think there
really will be something for ev
every comma for every believer
that's right that's right there's
nothing for the haters july 31st
we could give the haters something i
like haters or something all right
[Laughter]
how much is a comic-con ticket the price
has not been announced yet
but if you buy a comma two today on
nobel day take a look at the price
oh nabil day pricing field day pricing
uh
sweet sweet i'm glad oh it's nice oh
good the subtotal shows up right
have we had any sales yeah
do you check uh if we've had i can't
check on that spotify login
website fully live um i think soldier
boy as a rene
branded comma two
i don't even follow that you know what
chris do we have any uh
blue oh do we have any special blue
do people know there's a there's about
eight
blue comma twos
they're the most rare i don't think
they're built into real combat twos
maybe we send one out on a field day
ones might be blue
yeah i think we send at least one i
think yeah one lucky nobel day buyer
will get a blue on
my god you raised up price yeah it's
21.98 now in honor of nobel day
meal day it's the veal day yeah we'll
make one of them blue
they did not raise the price we did
though no no you were money printer
what's that rap song
this is a meme price uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys know uh
send it up by
by by kanye this is what i'm thinking of
let me be clear the sides of the common
two are black but the actual
device is blue yeah
are we gonna get struck oh for copyright
only if we play a couple of seconds
[Music]
yeah well you know so let's just say
that i'm gonna set this pitch up and
like it might not go down
so you know you guys might this might be
the best price you can ever get in at
but it might not be it might be like e
we'll just feel it out tomorrow we'll
fill it up tomorrow like we
tomorrow might be extended nobel day
um yeah you know look at the price of e
well max s says it's a great price
it is a great price it ends with eight
bar that's a great sounding number no
fours no
be a week nabil
yo that's a way to make money did you
invite media
uh to the yeah we're inviting some media
but who's the media anymore
you know what i mean you are the music
uh oh claw 320 wants to buy one for
three thousand dollars
i know that you want your own day too oh
i know but
nabeel did it first bro yeah sorry
like ray jay
oh people should be able to type in an
amount they want to pay it'll only go
through if it's over a certain amount
i do think that's funny uh are we
launching something new at comic-con
uh yes we're launching something new at
comic-con and you will be able to get it
if you have a comic chat
it's something we've talked about for a
bit i think it's gonna line up perfectly
with comic con we're obviously not going
to tell you what it is
um but it's coming to your comma 2. uh
so yeah there's that alex you know what
it is
what is it
oh yeah it's going to come to the
comments i think i think that's when
we're going to announce it comic con i
think is when that goes live you know
free live stream of comic con yes there
will search money for the live stream
or maybe we make it if you buy if you
own a common device you know a common
device can come free otherwise you'll
buy a ticket to virtual comic-con yeah
we can do a virtual comic-con ticket
buy a ticket everyone can send their
disdain to that guy
um i'm just you know
big big yeah you guys know
you guys know no please free no we'll
probably make it free
i like free streaming but i do feel like
if you pay for it you're more likely to
watch
does start with a b and end with an l
i don't know where and when july 31st
it's in san diego
um all day to saturday
and uh here let me let me let me i'll
i'll i'll i'll leave you guys something
else
uh check this out
what is it oh you want to show them the
goods yeah um
temporal with stop lines do you guys
know what stop lines are
how are stop lines doing oh they're not
even overfitting anymore
um stop lines are red lights and stop
science
uh and you know big model is what's
going to make that possible
uh so there'll be some some some great
talks about stop lines and big model
uh at comic con um
but yeah i mean you'll see they then
you'll you'll see what it is
uh we're gonna announce comic-con
tickets
through discord um so if you're not in
our discord already
the way george just sits on his computer
with his legs crossed just exhibits
you're like an anthropologist here
observing
recently and i found out i'm in the 96th
percentile for testosterone
and this made me happy um nebula
genomics shout out nebula genomics
uh i also found out that i also have uh
what's that like asperger's or something
someone asked if you could buy with
common points um no but we will be
sending advanced invites to
all the top comma points holders that's
true everyone with top comma points
uh top contributors mostly you know
recognized contributors everyone else is
gonna get an announcement
the day before it's public is it gonna
go at green lights
you're gonna have to wait for uh comic
con to find out about that
and uh yeah if you're if you're if you
have a lot of common points
we'll send you the the secret invite uh
link early the tickets might even just
sell out to those people
yeah i mean the only way to really
guarantee a ticket is to buy
that yeah yeah sure
um show you top ten comma points we
still have a leaderboard on the website
yeah
just like still is it like still the old
crappy leaderboard yeah
no no it's oh my god it's so crappy wow
i haven't seen this in so long i can't
please go to the top let's go to the top
box these are everyone who's gonna be
invited wow i don't know how much brevin
drives
yo brevin's crushing it
um probably the top 20 here bugsy
uh who else we have superscape kevin
david z
c sours sjm maybe we can offer free
tickets to some of the really high
comm avoid people
wow yeah if you guys if any of you are
watching just message email me alex
comma
yeah dot ai see what we can do for you
uh now i was in the bottom four
percentile for things covet effects
according to nebular genomics which i
recommend to everybody
and the hacker app those are my two
product recommendations
along with comma twos ticket price is
going to be at least 99
there is going to be a vip ticket
that's going to be a little bit more but
at minimum
around 99 and that's going to include
lunch and dinner
yeah the tickets are not going to be
extravagantly priced
we're going to do this more based on uh
you know like
the city uh
the tickets when they would no we're not
you know comic-con is uh it's it's a
it's in the marketing budget
it's not in the it's not in the make
profit budget thank you
so yeah but uh
we might all you guys know about bonding
curves like unisocks
i just want to see a big curve that goes
up
yes um so maybe maybe we'll do a a
bonding curve style auction on cheap
eath
for uh comic con tickets
um isn't marketing selling out no
advertising is selling out
marketing that gives back to your
community is great there will be special
comic con
uh memorabilia i think you guys are
really gonna like it
um yeah advertising supports a scummy uh
business model it gives money to like
google and facebook
marketing like we're giving money to
like a local venue
and like some local caterers to put on a
cool event for the community
that's not a scam bros
self-driving hoodies oh hector wants to
know uh
can we sum up where we're at can we sum
up where we're at all right all right
all right so we saw this quote from the
beal
let me show the quote in discord in
discord and um
we got inspired we got inspired
when we heard that there were people out
there who would have easily
paid double uh we we made that a reality
and we doubled the price of the comma
too
today only is nabil day
um and in the ability comma two comes
with a
ticket to comic con
which is gonna be a sub 200 person event
we're waiting for the final head count
numbers
so i'm very certain it will sell out if
you want a guaranteed ticket
you can um acquire x number of
uh comma points be an important
contributor uh
or buy a comma 2 dev kit today
i am wearing a hat common
hat wow those were may exclusive those
are never gonna be again
no they're all gone there's no more
comma hats
wow i left one at your house because i
knew you'd forget but they're all gone
do you guys know about unisocks
this is the use you can do uh uniswap
made a pair of socks
and they put it on a bonding curve take
a look at the price of a pair of
unisocks
pump no but it's like actually those
socks like
flex i have 46 000 socks
let's see you're european is comma
allowed here the spirit of comma is
allowed anywhere in this
period of freedom is allowed make it a
vip ticket that's included with today's
purchase no that's a little much
it's a little much i think we'll give
you an option to upgrade your ticket
do we want to let someone who buys a
a device today vip ticket i think they
can upgrade it when the vip takes care
now we don't know what vip price is
going to be yet but we do know that vip
is going to include a sit-down dinner
with the whole common team and it's
going to be very limited so it's like
half team members and half
yeah yeah we're really looking like you
know to get that like maybe it's gonna
be like five thousand dollars for a
ticket we're trying to get like
automotive
executives to pay that kind of money
it's like a phone call but longer
um
and in person we just like vip
extravagantly overpriced
yeah like 99 for a normal ticket and
then five g's for a vip ticket
yeah uh how will we handle fan boys we
don't want those
i mean i mean if you want to like like
fanboys are really in
oh fanboys are really annoying like if
you want to show up to san diego and
like like buy a ticket and you're a fan
boy like
that's kind of the point of the
conference like you're looking
you know you're not getting you're not
going to root that out
but i mean one way that we handle it is
this is why we do it exclusively
right this is why we limit like bb we
make the tickets
launched slowly launched through the
community right like you didn't spend
your whole life gathering comma points
just to uh
you know be a fanboy you're committed to
the community you are
a community so of course you're welcome
what even is a fanboy
um george what keyboard do you have
anyone who asked that question oh got it
i have a happy hacking keyboard
professional too uh this is a 300
keyboard voice uh if you spend a lot of
money on a keyboard
you will not be any better of a hacker i
just bought it because i can't
since you didn't get a hat with your
mayor or can you order some other
apparel in a discount why didn't you get
a hat
because you ordered too late get in
early yeah we just we had a limited
supply
um july 31st
first yes
saturday the desk is uh
jarvis it's made by uh tony stark's
assistant
uh is that where you can follow this is
on stock open file no but we're working
on a bit
this is all gonna be announced at comic
con we got some big stuff
in the in the in the gas and brake
department coming out
at comic con which includes you know
uh 1995 compact
keyboard
i've never seen george stand at his desk
it does go up
all right you gotta head to your dentist
appointment
we got we got a couple more questions i
bought a
tooth camera yesterday and i stuck in my
mouth and i took pictures of all my
teeth
it was wild and one of them has a hole
in it so we're gonna fix that
um what kind of carpet is this it is
lawyer standard number three
this used to be some office of some
lawyers oh yeah we're looking for a new
office
what does it mean for hardware going
forward it means risk fine bros
risk architecture's gonna change
everything
yeah we're launching a car at comic-con
the rumors are true
the comic car is coming out it's gonna
go in both directions
um yeah let's see do we post on twitter
to explain the deal there yet
oh you know george uh spent a long time
in australia
not yet ah just like the moderately um
classes that frequently pick me up when
i called yeah doctor
should make some uh asmr videos of him
labeling uh
images oh yo we would put that on in
between talks if he wants to make that
kind of content
it's gonna be a comic-con and a a doctor
spector pj lao would like to get up and
talk a little about you know labeling
um you know they're at ten thousand now
and i also think this is the highest
quality second data set in the world
like when you compare it to cityscapes
or um
uh the napillary vistas
or god forbid canvid uh our data says
higher quality
like there's less mistakes there's way
less mistakes in our data set
than all the other ones um because you
know it was done with love
like i'm serious about that right like
like you know the people who work at
scale ai didn't care
they really didn't uh they were like oh
let's just get through the picture the
people here are like
yeah you can mislabel the lane but you
know it's your open pilot bros uh
so yeah okay we love brazilians
as a brazilian there'll be at least one
me there
uh please make a ticket announcement on
discord yeah i mean discord is one tier
like we have like it's gonna be like
tiered and like i hope it doesn't sell
out by the time it gets to discord
but the ogs are the people on this
youtube who bought comma twos on the
blda
or you know just paid uh yeah
upgrade your comments you do a new why
not hire people to do the labeling
because you can't motivate people to do
a good job
if you want people to do a good job like
you know we've tried to
you can't pay people to care we hired
these people we hired super annotate and
it was awful
um like there were so many mistakes and
they were just like there's no way to do
it better and like
we have a community that shows that's
clearly wrong you know who i hope is
coming
deanly whoa
we'll help dean lee out team lee gets a
free ticket [ __ ] i buy dean leah take it
from china
um if d lee reaches out like yo i want
to come like let's make it happen
i agree
um
cool thank you for watching the stream
okay
great day to buy a comic too it's a
great price
sometimes lower prices aren't always
better i want you to think about where
this higher price is going
it's going to fund development of open
pilot so uh
shout out to nabeel shout out to the bl
have a good day everybody